the European debt crisis visualized what
is the European debt crisis it's the
failure of the Europe the currency that
ties together 17 European countries in
an intimate but flawed manner over the
past three years Greece Portugal Ireland
Italy and Spain have all teetered on the
brink of financial collapse threatening
to bring down the entire continent and
the rest of the world how did it happen
uniting Europe for most of Europe's
history it's been at war with itself and
countries at war with each other tend to
do less business together Europe was
always a continent of trade barriers
tariffs and different currencies doing
business across borders was difficult
you needed to pay a fee to exchange
currencies
and you needed to pay a tariff e to buy
and sell to companies in other countries
that tended to stifle economic growth
then came World War two which devastated
Europe because the situation was so dire
the fastest way to rebuild Europe was to
begin to remove these barriers steel and
coal tariffs came down so that a steel
mill in one country could sell to a
builder in another this gave the
survivors an idea a unified Europe a
union across the continent that would
end all future Wars countries began to
band together toward this goal bringing
down trade barriers lowering the cost of
doing business
one of the last barriers to fall was the
Berlin Wall with the United Germany
Europe was ready 27 countries signed the
Maastricht Treaty and created the
European Union
this made doing business across borders
easier but there was still one major
obstacle the different currencies a
decade later they had won the euro
launched on January 1st 1999 countries
adopting the euro called the euro area
discontinued their own currencies they
also discontinued the road monetary
policies giving control to the newly
formed European Central Bank commonly
referred to as the ECB the euro area now
had one unified monetary policy but it
still had many different fiscal policies
a key reason for the current debt crisis
monetary policy versus fiscal policy you
see it's important to understand the
difference between monetary policy and
fiscal policy monetary policy controls
the money supply literally how much
money there is in the economy and what
the interest rates are for borrowing
money
fiscal policy controls how much money a
government collects and taxes and how
much it spends the government can only
spend as much as it collects in taxes
anything above that amount it has to
borrow this is called deficit spending
before the Euro countries like Greece
not only had to pay high interest rates
to borrow but they could only borrow so
much lenders weren't comfortable lending
them too much money but now that they
were part of the euro areas new United
monetary policy the amount they could
borrow skyrocketed smaller countries
suddenly had access to credit like never
before Greece and other countries which
previously could only borrow at rates
around 18 percent could now borrow for
the same low rate as Germany how
germany's credit card you see joining
the euro area is a lot like sharing a
credit card Germany's credit card
lenders now believe that if Greece was
unable to repay its loans Germany and
the other big economies of Europe would
step in and repay them because they were
now bound by a common currency with a
new abundance of cheap credit Greece and
other European countries were able to
adjust their fiscal policies and
increase spending to previously
impossible levels some countries
embarked on huge deficit spending
programs primarily for politicians to
get elected they made promises such as
more jobs and generous pensions all of
it paid for with the new money they
could now borrow the governments of
Greece Portugal and Italy accumulated
huge debts
however they were able to repay these
debts with more borrowed money as long
as the borrowing continued so did the
spending and the unbalanced fiscal
policies in Ireland in Spain
cheap credit fueled enormous housing
bubbles just as it did in the United
States credit flowed debt accumulated
and the economies of Europe became
tightly intertwined companies began
opening factories and offices across
Europe German banks lending to French
companies French banks lending to
Spanish companies and so on and so forth
this made doing business incredibly
efficient while at the same time tying
together the collective fate of the euro
area things continued this way as long
as credit was available and credit was
available until 2008 spurred by a
collapse in the US housing market a
credit crisis swept the globe bringing
borrowing to a halt
everywhere suddenly the Greek economy
couldn't function
[Music]
it couldn't borrow money to pay for all
the new jobs and benefits that created
it couldn't borrow the new money it
needed to pay its old debts this was a
problem for Greece but because of the
unified monetary policy it was also a
problem for all of Europe much of Europe
had been on a spending spree and
borrowed more money than it could ever
repay
but the problem is somebody has to pick
up the tab or else every country in the
euro area will suffer since the
countries that ran up the bill couldn't
repay everyone looked to Germany
austerity measures as the biggest and
strongest economy in Europe Germany
reluctantly agreed to help bail out the
debtor countries in other words Germany
agreed to repay the bill but only if the
debtor countries agreed to implement
strict austerity measures to ensure that
it would never happen again
austerity measures meant sucking it up
cutting spending borrowing less and
paying back more debt this sounds like a
simple solution right it's not first of
all nobody wants austerity austerity
means cutting government spending and
since the government is by far the
biggest spender in any economy when the
government cuts spending it cuts the
earnings of many of its citizens people
lose jobs they get angry they riot in
the streets and austerity also doesn't
automatically balance a country's budget
you see the government collects taxes
based on people's earnings
so when earnings are reduced the
government collects less in taxes they
still can't pay down their debts the
pain is so bad that it's almost
politically impossible to accomplish on
top of that there are huge cultural
differences within the euro area extreme
cultural differences Germany is very
financially responsible
ever since the terrible hyperinflation
the country experienced after World War
one it's been extremely inflation averse
and incredibly careful about spending
and borrowing in general Germans work
hard expect little in the line of state
benefits and meticulously pay all of
their taxes many Greeks on the other
hand enjoy generous state benefits and
don't pay taxes Greece has a terrible
problem it has never collected the
majority of the taxes it imposes on its
citizens and it's always been this way
joining the Euro just amplified it the
German view is that doesn't work if you
want our money you need our morals as
the debtor country's headed towards
default the whole continent of Europe
was in danger even though the economies
of the debtor countries are relatively
small they posed a huge threat because
the European financial system is so
interconnected precisely because of the
euro
remember the debtor countries borrowed
money from banks investors and other
governments throughout Europe as the
debtor countries get closer to default
everyone who lent them money becomes
weaker and everyone who lent those
lenders money also becomes weak
and so on and so forth a problem in one
country could reverberate across the
whole continent triggering a chain
reaction of default if Greece defaults
then Spain could default it'll Portugal
and Ireland to be next then France then
Germany pretty soon it could spread not
just across Europe but across the world
fiscal Union or breakup
the problem is even if the debtor
nations adopt austerity measures and
even if the bailout from Germany and the
stronger countries helps them pay down
their debts and avoid the immediate
crisis there's no system in place to
prevent this from happening again this
brings us back to that fundamental
division of monetary policy and fiscal
policy ultimately the euro area requires
a fiscal Union to match its monetary
union or neither that is there must be a
political organization with authority to
set fiscal policy within every euro area
country it must have the power to cut
spending raise taxes and set laws a
fiscal union like this could actually
prevent excessive borrowing and spending
[Music]
however this is an enormous ly
complicated and unpopular notion
it means surrendering sovereignty to a
higher power in essence a United States
of Europe yet without a centralized
fiscal union countries will continue to
run deficits accumulate debt degrade the
value of the euro and threatens
stability of Europe can Europe take the
necessary steps and create a fiscal
union alongside the monetary union or
will the monetary union break up and the
Euro disappear
[Music]
[Music]